voilà et nous rejoignons tout de suite à
kde nos envoyés spéciaux très spéciaux
même jean françois téaldi andré quentris
qui souffrent beaucoup pensaient dont
ils passent ce toutes leurs journées à
regarder des films à l'intérieur alors
bonsoir deux films d'amour aujourd'hui
au festival de cannes et des plus
curieux puisque là c'est l'amour d'une
femme envers un chapeau et c max mon
amour avec charlotte rampling un film de
nagisa oshima d'ailleurs charlotte
rampling s'en est expliqué comment une
femme pouvait tomber amoureuse d'un
chimpanzé est attendu jeudi à baisser il
allait voir
la seule question que je voulais
demander à la grille sotchi mc alger
avant de
de serre ce film j'ai demandé jusqu'où
ils allaient aller avec les relations
avec maxime charrette et donc il m'a
expliqué en deux trois mots ça me
suffisait donc j'avais absolument pas
d'angoissé à jouer c'est sept films avec
un chimpanzé le deuxième film a trait à
l'amour je voulais dit puisqu'il s'agit
d'un film avec kelly michel propos dajla
view iloveyou et bien c'est ce que
répond un porte clés
chaque fois qu'on le siffle je sais bien
que se structurer
le voir en super combien tu vas plus tu
peux pas payer
c'est un canot ce cadeau du ciel genre
pour les mains
cette armoire vous fait un plaisir en
tournant ce film a tout à fait c'est un
coup politique j'avais envie de faire un
film un peu plus d'auteurs je léguerai
savait pas bien cher c'est
systématiquement mais l'âge des faits
j'étais très content de le dire j'ai
adoré tourner une version allégée la
mutuelle on s'est formidablement entendu
c'est à dire on s'est bien marré genre
pour les mêmes bases tenait sous une
bonne étoile vraiment signes du zodiaque
scoumoune ascendant monde le cul je suis
jaloux que christophe aime le pointelier
je préférerais qu'elle prendrait pied ne
soit pas là et comment ça se fait alors
que vous arrivez à lui faire des radios
parce que je suis fou minutes le best-of
être la femme de travailleurs immigrés
turcs en allemagne et pas plus
réjouissant que de la femme de
travailleurs immigrés en france 40
mètres carrés en allemagne du dur que tu
es fiq basher pose le problème des
relations entre l'homme et la femme dans
un appartement de 40 mètres carrés elle
ne peut pas sortir un l'accroître
il pense donc également le problème des
relations entre une femme musulmane et
son épouse et c'est tous les avantages
de la semaine internationale de la
critique et de présenter de tels films
sur la croisette
bah
tiens
oh
je suis
benoît maxime viville combat des chefs
diniz avoir le sens de la chambre ma
place et mon idée et c'était de raconter
l'histoire et la ville leur vie de ces
gens là qui sont perdus dans une société
qui n'est pas le même religion que qui
sont tout à fait perdre le sait je
voulais voter leur histoire leur vie